So let's have a look back at the laws of NP completeness,
and the laws of NP completeness, of course, is a book that only holds unless P=NP.
If anybody ever proves P=NP, then we can recycle this book here or delete the e-book.
So what do the laws of NP completeness say--they say, "No polynomial algorithm."
So now it's time to think like lawyers and try to put loopholes into the statement here
and there's two loopholes that you can poke into this.
One is that we only say, "No polynomial time." We do not say, "Exponential time."
What do I mean by that? Well, what about a running time like 2^√n.
It's not exponential time--it's called sub-exponential because you don't have the n as it is
appear in the exponent, but it's also not polynomial time because you have
some function of n up here in the exponent.
A running time like this actually conforms with the law and it has an excellent speedup.
So let's think about this for a minute. Let's say n=50.
If n=50, what is the speedup of 2^√n versus 2^n. Of course, we're going to do this as a quiz.
Is it over a million, is it over a billion, or is it over a trillion.
Of course, I only want you to select one answer here, the best possible one.